Beautiful. Okay. Let's do this. So guys, welcome to I think this is like the seventh call that
we've actually done with this format. Let me get my mic a little bit closer. Again,
we used to do as many people as we could on the Facebook group vanity metrics. Let's get
a whole bunch of people that also last thing, Jason, please make sure everyone's muted.
I think it's default to mute everybody. But if you see that it just distracts on the call.
Just mute everybody. Anyway, this is I think our seventh call. What we're going to do and what I
always do is if you stay on this call till the end and you have your camera on obviously,
then we're going to screenshot everybody that's on this call with around like the last five
minutes and we're going to automatically create and send you guys a digital resource that covers
the things that we talk about in this call. So it's basically going to be the cheat sheet,
the notes that normally you'd have to take or that you should take the highlights. I don't want you
to sit here and take notes on everything because we're going to send that to you if you stay on
the call. What I would rather you do what I want you to do is I want you to just listen and I want
you to the things that come to your mind, the things that the ideas that you have, that's what
I want you to write down because I'm going to send you the information that I'm going to talk about.
I want you to think about and I want you to write down the things that come to your mind. So as I
talk today, you're going to have these ideas that I'm going to spark because of things that I say
and that's what I want you to write down. Also, I am going, because this is a more intimate
like session, I am going to leave time for Q&A. So if you guys do have questions and you don't
want to forget those questions, just start dropping them in the comments and I'm going to
probably Jason read them for me towards the end. Try to stick to competition questions,
but if you have other questions and we have time, I'll also
fill those as well. So that said, guys, let's get into this. Again, anything that I talk about,
and I'll start with this actually, just for the person or the people that don't know, I know some
of you guys have been on a few of these calls, so this might be redundant. That's fine. This is my
eighth year doing this business. I don't know how many niches, probably well over 30 niches
I've tried this in. I don't know how many cities, probably over 100 cities. I've lost millions,
like literally lost millions of dollars. I've gone $60,000 of debt. I've almost quit twice.
And I mean, seriously, like when I almost quit in 2019, I had another sales job completely
lined out, commissions agreed upon, ready to just shut down my agency, ready to get rid of
everyone on my team and just be a sales guy. And I figured it out and I stuck with it.
And then in 2020, we finally figured this out. There were some missing pieces. For those of you
guys that are in other programs, for those of you that are learning rank and rent, the old school
antiquated method where you build a website, you put in all this time and you wait for it to rank,
you guys are doing it the wrong way. And I truly mean that. And I'm telling you that
you're never going to scale doing it how you're doing it. You will never scale.
And I know that from experience. So I used to call this the most perfectly broken business
model on the internet because it's broken. It's perfect because it checks all the boxes. It's
recurring. You own the asset, it's scalable, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. But it's broken
because you are rolling the dice. Meaning you're building a website, you're hoping that it ranks,
and if it doesn't, you're screwed. If it does, you're hoping that there's leads. If there are
leads, you're hoping there's a business owner that's hungry. If there's a hungry business owner,
you're hoping you can sell them. And all the while you're waiting six to nine months to even
check this out. You don't even know. That's why it's broken and that's why it's unscalable.
But once you start flipping this on its head, once you start actually selling the deal first
and pre-selling the deal, then you start to be able to scale. You're able to go into a market,
spend a couple hundred dollars, see if it's actually a good market, and then confidently
go in using somebody else's money. That's how you scale this thing. And so I think about it the
same way as real estate. If I was going to build a massive portfolio of real estate portfolio,
it would be very, very, very, very difficult for me to do it if I had to pay for all the houses
myself. Imagine I had to go buy all the houses with my own money, do the down payments or
no, not even the down payments, the construction loan, all of it, and then try to scale. On the
flip side, what if I could go and I could use everyone else's money and I could already have
a guaranteed renter? I could go and build this thing as big as I wanted to. And guys, some of
the biggest real estate companies in the world, there's a company in Dubai called EMAR. This is
what they do. Every single person that comes to that city, they stand in the mall, they send out
flyers, they're hitting you up. They are everywhere. And what they do is basically they bring you in,
they give you the presentation, they tell you why they're the best, and they get you to put
money down on a project, on a specific unit, you pay a chunk upfront, and then they put you on a
payment plan, and they basically have you pay for the project. They have little risk and they know
that it's done and sold by the time it's finished. So if some of the biggest, I think it might be
the biggest or one of the biggest in the world, for sure in Dubai, companies, construction companies
in the world is doing this, then why the heck wouldn't we do this? It's the same exact concept.
So for those that are hearing other advice, I want you to think about that person that's giving you
advice, that program, that whatever, maybe it's someone you follow on YouTube. How much money are
they actually making from this model? What you're going to find is most of the time they're not even
in the game A, and if they are, they're not making any money. And a lot of times you're getting this
advice, build, build, build, build more websites. Why? You shouldn't be building more websites unless
it works. And I've said this example before, but going and building 100 or 200 websites
without pre-selling them is like building 100 units. And then you open your eyes one day and
you're like, oh my gosh, we forgot to put toilets in these things. And I know that's kind of an
extreme example, but it's like, guys, that's what I did. I went into the wrong niche. I went into the
wrong freaking niche. I built like 50 of these things and pulled my head out and went, oh my gosh,
I just built 50 of these in the wrong niche. I got lucky on the first one and it was complete
fluke. And then I built 49 more in the wrong freaking niche because I wasn't pre-selling.
So that said guys, I've been in the game a long time. Anything that I talk about on these calls
is from experience. And if I haven't done it, I'll tell you. And 99% of the time, I won't even cover
it anyway. Okay. So my promise to you guys, my goal to you guys for this call is that by the end
of this training, you're going to have a solid understanding of competition with this business
model. And you're going to be able to see the signs, especially the telltale signs of high
competition, as well as layups, low competition, areas that if you go into, they're going to be
quick wins. They're going to be really high margins, you know, able to rank really quickly,
not have to spend a lot of money on ads. I'm going to, I'm confident you'll be able to understand
and see those areas. Now, is this going to give you a perfect understanding of competition?
Of course not. I'm not going to be able to do that in the next 40 minutes,
but I'm going to be able to give you guys a good 20,000 foot view, enough to have an idea. And then
from there, you can build on that. Okay. And again, just for anyone that wasn't on the last
couple of calls, guys, these calls, my goal with these calls is to give you value, just like with
the, when we give free leads to a business owner, right? When we call a business owner,
we don't just call them up. Hey, let me, you know, you want to buy some leads? No, that's not what
we do. Right. Well, Hey, you want me to rank you on Google? No, that's what everybody does. What do
we do? We call them, Hey, let me give you a couple of free leads. And then we can talk. Let's talk
about business after I've given you some free leads, right? We're being different. I'm doing
that with you guys, because I know that you guys, if you're on this call, with the exception of like
one or two of you, which I can tell are in, uh, I think, yeah, I think Shane is the only one,
obviously Jason, but Shane's in digital landlords. And by the way, Shane, if you have to hop off,
you're going to get all this, all this stuff anyway. So you don't have to stay on since
you're in digital landlords, but, um, everyone else, I know you're interested in this business
model. You're interested in, uh, in, you know, taking the next step and making this a thing,
not just something that's a, that's a hobby. Um, I know what you guys are looking for. You're looking
for the right information. And so what am I going to do? I'm going to give you that right information,
at least a bit of it for free before I ever expect you to work with me, but make no mistake,
this is the same as free leads. My goal with my free group is to earn your business. That's,
that's it. Obviously like, okay, I think I'm a pretty decent person, but that's, I'm not,
I'm not just doing this out of the goodness of my heart. So that's why I'm doing these calls. Okay.
Um, and so it's, it's kind of like this example that I gave a couple of weeks ago.
My goal is I'm basically the guy that's trying to get you, um, enough information and enough
confidence with this model to get you to the gym, right? If we're talking about the gym,
I'm going to get you there. I'm going to, I'm going to give you enough confidence to go buy
a pair of shoes or get a pair of shoes, get the, get to the gym and, and not feel dumb when you're
in the gym, right? However, in order for you to have the body you want in order for you to lose
the fat you want to build the muscle you want, there's no way I can cover it on these calls.
So that's where we have the program that comes in. Just like you would have to get a trainer,
they would tell you the diet, they would show you that hold your hand. That's the difference,
but I will give you enough information, hopefully enough inspiration to take those first steps,
get excited and get in the, in the metaphorical gym, so to speak. So here's the plan really quick
about what's going to, this call is going to look like we're going to spend the next 20 minutes,
20, probably 20 top, maybe 18 on what I want to cover. Then we're going to open this for Q and A
and I'm probably going to keep it to the comment section, but if we have time,
I could also bring you guys on live. And I think that's a really good time. And basically
guys, you're, you're basically getting me and there's only what 10 of you on,
you're getting me to answer your exact questions. So take advantage of those. And if I can answer
it, I will, if I can, I'll be honest with you. Okay. So here's the plan for today's call. Number
one is we're going to talk about the factors that actually matter with competition. Number two,
we're going to talk about telltale signs of highly competitive areas. Three, we're going to talk about
telltale signs of low hanging fruit, AKA layups. Number four, we're going to be talking about what
it means and what you should think when you see an Angie's List and home advisor. And then also
what to do when you spot, what to do, what to think about when you spot other lead generators.
So with that said, let's get right into the call. What I'm going to do really quick. Let me close
my door because my kids are still sleeping and then we're going to get, that's going to be two
seconds. Okay. So let's go, let's get right into this guys. Again, if you have comments, questions,
drop them right now, but take advantage of this guys. It's crazy because I, the reason I do my
YouTube channel, the reason I share so much is when I first was getting into this business,
it was so interesting to me. It really caught my attention. I was really excited about it.
There was a podcast that this guy did that was talking about this. And I swear to you guys,
I listened to this thing like, I'll say like three times in a month or something like that.
I just couldn't get this out of my head. I wanted more and more and more information.
And the thing that I kept running into is like, I kept asking myself,
how do I know like that I should listen to this advice? You know, because this sounds good,
but what is that? And the truth is the person that was actually giving the advice
wasn't even in the game anymore. And the most money they'd ever made was like $30,000 in a
single month. And come to find out, I don't think that was very months in a row, maybe even just one
month in a row. And so I never had somebody who had made a million dollars in this business that
I could listen to. Okay. Much less get on a call with 10 or less people and ask questions. So you
guys need to take advantage of these calls because I'm literally going to answer any questions that
you guys have. Okay. So first things first, let's talk about the factors that actually matter
with competition. I'm going to give you the high level. Basically, there's three things.
Number one is you need to look at the age of the domain. Number two, you want to look at the
content. Number three, you want to look at the backlinks. And I'll add a fourth is you want to
look at the cost per click. Okay. Now, how do you discover these things is I'm going to give
you a quick little tip. And I think I've talked about this in the free group. There is an extension
on Chrome called SEO quake. And you guys can literally just go download that on S on, on
Chrome and enable it. And it will show you, there's a bar that will show you. And if we have time,
maybe at the end, I can actually just show you an example, but that's going to actually show you
how many backlinks each website has. It's going to give you a quick link to the who is where you
can see the age of the domain. And then you obviously can kind of eyeball the content, right?
For CPC, you can go use a bunch of different tools. And also with backlinks, guys, the tool,
this SEO quake, it's literally called SEO and then Q U A K E. I have it on all of my computers.
It's free. And by the way, I always use Chrome. You don't have to, I just found that it's very
convenient because the Chrome store anyway, it'll show you how many backlinks. Now, if the area
looks competitive, right? And there's a good content, the domains are old, et cetera. You're
going to want to go a step further and you're going to want to look at the quality of the backlinks,
because it's not about how many backlinks a website has. It's about the quality of the
backlinks. And what I mean by that, and that we can do a whole training on backlinks. But
if I get a backlink from, let's just say a local review website, right? That's decent. And it might
help if I'm building a website in St. George, Utah, because it's a little bit relevant because
of it's St. George, right? However, if I compare that to a backlink that I get from, let's say,
Forbes, right? Forbes.com gives me a backlink. There's no competition. I would much rather
have one backlink from Forbes than a hundred backlinks from all the little review websites
in St. George, because the quality, it matters and the quality is much more important in quantity.
So guys, number one, age of domain. Number two, content. Number three, backlinks. Number four,
CPC. Also as a rule of thumb, make sure I'm going to put this in the notes. Hold on.
I'm going to put this in the notes, less than $5. And I could show you guys my Google Ads spending
and my average cost over, I don't think I have it on this phone. Maybe I can check out the exact,
it's definitely less than $5. Let me see if I have Google Ads here. I don't have it on this phone.
So if I pulled this up, my average spend is like $3.50 or $3.70 across $1.5 million spend.
If you guys are going into areas, make sure that the cost per click of the main keywords
is less than $5. And if it's not, don't do it. Period. I don't care how good it looks,
do not do it. Just my two cents. Okay. And what do I know? I've only made millions of dollars
doing this. Okay. So that's the factors that actually matter. Okay. And if you have questions,
these are perfect questions to ask here in about 10 minutes when we have questions. Okay.
Number two, what are the telltale signs of a highly competitive area?
Here's, I'm just going to give you, this is the thing, this is kind of the litmus test.
If I see this, I just don't even touch it. Okay. And what it is guys is when you guys are looking
at an area, because what you want to do is if you pick a city, you pick a niche, you have to make
sure that you're going to be able to get in and rank the website. Because if you can't get in and
rank the website, then this business model isn't what this business model is. This is a rank and
rent business model, right? You need to be able to get in, rank the website so that the calls become
free and the margins become fat. And so if I look at an area, let's just say Las Vegas concrete.
So that's an easy example to use. If I look at Las Vegas concrete, there's a lot of, you know,
we know the niche works. We know there's a lot of people searching for concrete because it's a big
population, but I look at it and it's really competitive. And it's going to be in the websites
that are at the top of Google are really good websites. They have old domains. They have
really good content. They have good backlinks. Even though there's a good opportunity. Once I
rank, I have to be honest with myself and go, what are the actual chances of me ranking? How
much work is it actually going to take for me to rank? And is it going to be worth the squeeze?
And that those are the questions that you have to ask yourself, because sometimes as good as it is,
it's not worth it guys. There are businesses that are really good out there. You know,
that's what's a really good business is solar. I have friends. I have a neighbor slash friend.
It also my kids football coach. He makes a lot of money and he does solar, but he got into the
right area at the right time and he's been doing it for 10 years. And so if I look at solar and
I'm like, I'm just going to get into it. It's so competitive right now. Yeah, I could, I could,
but you know how much, you know, how much competition is in that business. It's insane,
right? Roofing also a good business, but it's a very competitive business, right? So we have
to look at those things. So a telltale sign that it's a very highly competitive area is you always
want to search. You always want to clear your browsing history and you want to search for the
main keywords. And that's a whole nother training in itself is what are the main keywords? How do
you build a keyword list? How do you know what your core keyword list, all these things we cover,
obviously in depth of the training, but we have covered in bits and pieces inside of the Facebook
group that you guys can go search. But once you get your core keyword list, you want to clear
your browsing history because you want it to be a fresh search as if you're somebody who's never
searched before. And you want to search all these terms. So concrete Las Vegas, concrete contractor,
Las Vegas, concrete company, Las Vegas, concrete sidewalk, Las Vegas, concrete walkway or driveway,
Las Vegas, right? Las Vegas, Nevada, all these things we want to just, we want to do multiple.
This is one of the things that they didn't teach me in my first training. I didn't realize that
you should probably search more than one keyword. I was the dummy that was typing towing Huntsville.
And I would, I would literally made my decision based on that. I looked at the term towing
Huntsville. I searched it. It looked decent. I didn't even really know what I was looking at.
And I based my entire decision of going into towing Huntsville on one term. And that's it.
And literally I got so lucky that it actually was low-hanging fruit. I didn't do it. It wasn't
because I was good. It wasn't because I knew what I was doing. I just got lucky, right? But guys,
you have to look at multiple terms because let's say that towing Huntsville or Las Vegas concrete
is very easy to rank for, right? There's not much competition, blah, blah, blah. But let's say
Las Vegas concrete contractors is highly competitive. Las Vegas concrete company is
highly competitive. Concrete sidewalk is highly competitive. Then out of all the terms that I want
to rank for out of seven terms, only one of them looks feasible. I'm not going into that area. So
you have to look at more than one. So here's the deal is once you search, once you number one,
figure out ability keyword list, and you have that keyword list, you're going to search for those
keywords with the area. Okay. At the end of it. So Las Vegas concrete or concrete Las Vegas plus
the other seven terms. And I'm going to have all the tabs pulled up to what I usually do.
Then what I'm going to do is I'm going to pull all those up and I'm going to look,
this is just a quick way. And I don't know why this is the case, but I can almost
always guarantee that when this happens, it's highly competitive. Okay. If you start looking
at all, let's say you open the first tab and you, what I always do is I look at who's actually in
the maps. Okay. Now I don't spend a bunch of time in maps to this day. I have kind of just
set it aside. If I can always try to get the map, the Google, my business, but I don't spend time
obsessing over it because I realized if I can rank organically and I can get my ads running,
I don't need the maps. The maps is a bonus. So for those of you that think you need map,
but you don't. Okay. Promise you, I built a million dollar company without even
worrying about maps. In fact, most, most of my projects, when I hit the million dollar mark in
2020 did not even have Google GMBs. Okay. You don't need them. You can make a million dollars
without them. That's a fact. Okay. But so, but for whatever reason, there is a strong correlation
between who's ranking in the maps and who's ranking organically. And so what I look at guys
is I go and I open all the tabs and I look at who's the number one in the maps. Okay. Let's say it's
Bob's concrete. Okay. Then I'm going to open up second tab is Bob's concrete in the maps. Yes.
Okay. Is it in the same spot? Okay. Bob's concrete is ranked the first, the first listing in the maps
for the first two terms. And I'm going to look at the third and I'm looking at the fourth and I'm
going to look at all seven or all five. I would say minimum five up to seven keywords. And guys,
I'm going to do that. And I'm going to look at if that Bob's concrete is ranking for the majority
of those terms in the same spot in the maps. Okay. And I'm going to do that. I'm going to see
what the main, like what are the main companies ranking in the maps? Now, again, I just said,
we're not worried too much about math, but for some reason, this is a strong indicator
of a highly competitive area. Once I do that, guys, I'm going to go and I'm going to look at
those same exact terms. I'm going to open those tabs back up and I'm going to look who's ranking
organically. If you're brand new and you don't know what I'm talking about underneath the maps
is the organic section, the actual listings, right? So now I'm going to look who's ranking
on page one and at the top of page one. So I'm going to go, okay, Bob's concrete.
He ranked in the maps, number one for five out of the seven terms. And he's ranking number one
for five of the terms and number two on page one for two of the terms. This guy's basically glued
to the top. I'm going to make a mental note and I'm going to go to the next one. That's Sally's
concrete. And we do the same thing and we go to the next one. Okay. If you guys see the same three
companies showing up over and over and over for the majority of the terms, if you're doing seven
and that's four of them, or if you're doing five and there's three of them and the same three
companies are showing up for the majority of those terms. Okay. Number one and B, if those companies
are also showing up on the organic on page one, especially at the top for the majority of the
keywords, you need to get the heck out of there. I don't care how low the CPC is. I don't care how
bad you want to do it. Do not do it. And for whatever reason, and this is my theory is that
Google wants to give the business to the local guys. We're the ones that spend the freaking money
with Google ads. We're the ones. And when I say local, I'm representing the local guy, right?
Even though I don't own the concrete company, I am representing the local concrete company.
They know that we're the ones that are going to always be there. We have to, we need Google. We're
the ones that are going to spend the money on Google ads, et cetera. They would like to give
the spots to the local guy. They really would. And I truly like think that, and that's, we're
going to get into some others, some, when we talk about home advisor, I think if they can,
they like to give it to local. So if I see people that are ranking again and again and again in the
maps, they're also ranking organically. It's basically like Google telling us out loud,
Hey, I've chosen my people, man. These are my recommended people. And when people search in
this city, they've proven that they're the guys, they're the gals. And for whatever reason, guys,
if you see those same companies showing up again and again in the maps and also showing up
organically, especially at the top, it's too competitive. Especially if you don't have any
money coming in, especially if you haven't gotten out of your job. Now, if you've gone and you're
at like Jason, Jason, Jason, what did you just hit by the way in your agency? What are you at per month?
Cool story. I, I closed three deals in the last seven days. So that's crazy. I closed two deals
last night. So we're at almost 14,000, three, we're at 13,000 right now, but closer to the
$14,000 range. Sick dude. Once we get off that call, this call, I want you to post that in the
group, in the free group, because it just inspires people. By the way, Jason, when did you start
this business? Like a year ago? Yeah, much less than a year ago. I actually didn't get my
head underwatered, like actually diving straight into this business model until the end of January
of this year. That's dope, dude. For, and, and just real quick, this is one of his calls about, but
did you, were you previously in digital marketing? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I did SEO.
You did SEO and you decided to convert to this? Yeah. So I'm sure a lot of you guys have found
Nick's YouTube channel, right? Everything makes so much sense. So if any of you guys come from
RankinRent or SEO, this business model makes so much sense. And it's all, it's all paid off.
Literally, all I do is I just follow Nick's steps that he's laid out for me. The next thing I know,
I'm on a closing call and a guy's handing over his credit card. It's really that simple.
14K, that's, that's, that's amazing, bro. Good job. I didn't even know that. So congrats on the 14K.
Thanks, man. And I think you could probably be a testament that like,
when I found this as well, guys, when there's a process that works, if you just follow it,
it works. And if it works once, it's going to work again. And I don't know if you noticed
that Jason, but like, when you first follow the process, it's almost like, you almost don't
believe it can be that simple. I'm not saying easy. I'm saying simple. Right. And you follow
it and it works. You're like, no way. Right. And, and he just do it again and again. And then
I promise you, and I'm begging you, Jason, because everyone does this. I think you might
have even gone through this already, but, and then everyone gets too smart and they,
they try too early to innovate. There's nothing wrong with innovation, but if it works,
it's like, okay, Jason's got to $14,000 per month. So why not just go do that eight more times?
Like you, you know what I mean? Or when I go to that, you know, you do that four more times,
you're at $60,000 a month. You're probably with, with the profit margin, you're probably making
close to, you know, half a million dollars a year in your pocket, you know, but we get too
smart and we're like, oh, I'm going to go learn Facebook ads or whatever. But yeah, just, I mean,
have you seen, and you could completely disagree, but what I've seen is that when you have a process
that works and you follow it, you just follow it exactly to a T because the person that's teaching
you it, as long as they're credible, they're saying the things they're saying for a reason.
Yeah, yeah, for sure. One thing I can say also is even though I have all of your resources in front
of me, sometimes like I was getting on a roll, right? So there was a few steps that I decided,
oh, I, I got this, like, I'm not going to apply this step, you know, this should be a lay down and,
and I lost the deal because I wasn't listening to that one thing Nick was telling me to do,
whatever it is, there were so many things throughout the process that,
you know, to be honest, I feel like I should be at $20,000 per month
because I chose to ignore certain things that you were telling me to do.
So it's, it's not, it requires a lot of hard work, but you have to do
things correctly. You can't just go out there and just ask somebody to hand you their money or
take these free leads and work with me. Like you have to qualify the business owner
that there's a whole thorough process that you have to go through with vetting your business owner
and qualifying them before they even waste your time in the first place.
Yeah. And it's just like, I've used this example. It's like having the perfect recipe for the
perfect chocolate cake, right? It, you know, you can go and try to put the sugar in at a different
time and you're just risk it. You make, you could try to use a different brand of sugar. You could
try to use brown sugar instead of white sugar. You could try to whatever for glow the flower.
But if you just follow the recipe, the perfect cake is going to come out. If you decide not
to follow it, then you're, you don't know. And you're just kind of up in the air. So
anyway, appreciate you, you jumping in on that. This Salim guy, you can just remove him because
he's too late to the call. That's in the waiting. Oh, he, he said that he had a license issue.
So you can let him in, you can let him in. Okay. Okay. Real quick. Telltale signs that we're going
to get into questions that everybody has. So guys, on the other hand, what are the telltale signs
of low hanging fruit? What are the telltale signs of a layup? What are the telltale signs? If I see
this thing, I'm going in no matter what. And that is really, really simple. It's two things. Number
one is it's the opposite of what I just explained, which means if you do your, your research, if you
clear your browsing history, you search your five to seven terms and you see that the companies in
the maps are completely scattered. It's different companies. It's Bob, then it's Sally, then it's
Frank, then it's Las Vegas concrete. Then it's super concrete and they're all different. And
underneath in the organic, they're all different. And most of them are on page two or on page three.
And it's just a big jumble, mumble, jumble. That's a good sign. That's a, a strong indicator
that it's actually not competitive because it's not consistent. And so basically the way I view
it is Google's trying to figure out who the best person is. And for each term, they're kind of
sending people to different companies. And so whenever I see a scattering or I see that there's
a bunch of different companies showing up in the maps and there's no consistency and there's no one
company that's dominating. I love that. That gets me really excited. That's number one. Number two,
this is when I get really excited is if you guys are searching your terms, you search your seven
terms, okay, your five terms, concrete, concrete contractors, concrete company, et cetera. And you
have at least one company in the, in the maps that's showing up consistently for the top three
across all the terms. And that company does not have a website. Okay. And what I mean by that is
it is possible to get a Google my business or Google business profile and get it ranked
and not even have a website. It is possible. And if you come across this guys and you see it's that,
that one, let's say it's, let's say it's called a Las Vegas, Las Vegas, number one concrete company.
That's the listing and they're showing up for all seven terms, all seven terms they're showing up
for. Okay. In the maps and you look and you go and you're like, wait, where's their website?
And it's, they don't even have a website. It's literally doesn't even have a link for a website.
It's just a listing guys. I can tell you I'm, I'm going into that. I'm going into it. Cause I know
that I'm going to be able to rank that pretty dang quickly. And I'll tell you an example of when I
did this, um, I had this client in, uh, in, in St. George and I can't, I can't even remember,
but it was in a specific niche and I was doing the research in a city called Cedar city,
which is about 45 minutes to an hour north of here. And I just, for fun, I went, I did all the
terms and guys, I think it was not only one, but I think two of the top three didn't have websites
for all the terms. And literally I don't believe in rank and rent. I truly do not believe in rank
and rent because I think it's a waste of time, but I was, I've done this enough that when I saw it,
I also had enough search volume. It also had low CPC and I already had a client because I had that
client in St. George. I knew they'd buy the leads in Cedar city. I just went and I called Francesca
or I text her, I slacked her and I said, Hey, buy the domain for Cedar city, whatever.com
build the website. She's like, are you sure? We usually do the one page. I'm like, no,
just build a website. We built a website, no backlinks, nothing did. We did our rate,
everything else normal, just how we know what we did, you know, sound SEO. We built it within
three months. That thing was completely glued to the top and it stayed there. Okay. And I, and,
and so I'm telling you guys, if you see the, the same company showing up over and over and over
in the maps for the top three, for the main search terms, and they have no website, that's a really
good sign. You should get excited because it's going to be relatively easy to rank. Okay. Last
two things. What does it mean? We see a home advisor and Angie's list. It means it's, it's,
it's a good thing. Okay. It's a good thing. Don't get scared. Don't think, oh my gosh,
it's home advisor. It's Angie's list. No, the reason why it's good is because guys,
if you see home advisor, that means that especially obviously home advisor is going to be in the,
in the organic underneath the maps. If you see home advisor showing up for every one of the search
terms, what that means is that home advisor is ranking their page over everyone else's website.
What I mean by that is it's homeadvisor.com forward slash Kansas city or forward slash
concrete slash Kansas. I don't know what their, their structure is, but whatever their link
structure is, it's, they're, they're ranking a page over a website. And that, that is defying
logic, which means like, it's always easier to rank a website. If I have a, you know, let's call
it a Las Vegas concrete.com. And I am, I am targeting Las Vegas only, and I'm targeting
concrete only. And I'm going against somebody who is, you know, best concrete contractor.com
forward slash Las Vegas. They're trying to rank their single page against my domain. And I have a,
I have an advantage. And so if I see that home advisor is ranking for all the terms, I don't
run. I love, I actually prefer. So if you guys see home advisor, Angela's showing up at the top of
Google, good sign. Okay. Lastly, guys is what to do, what to do when you spot another lead gen.
I had this completely backwards. I thought that if I saw another lead gen, I got so upset. I was
like, oh my gosh, that's saturated. This business model, guys, this is back in 2016, 17, 18, 19.
I was thinking this. If I saw another lead generator, it completely put me off. And I was
like, gosh dang it. I should have come here earlier. I missed my, my, you know, I missed
my window, all these different things. And then one day, and I've told the story before,
and by the way, it's the last story I'm going to tell them. We're going to get the Q and A.
We have 10 minutes. If you guys have questions, drop them in the comments or yeah. In the comments
section is I'm looking at St. George tree service. Okay. And I look at it and I find another lead
generator and I'm like, gosh freaking dang it. I was late to the game. So I'm like, all right,
I'm going to go. I'm going to figure out who it is. I go, I do the who is, and they didn't buy
the privacy. So I could, I found their name and I'm like, let me just look. And I looked in one of
my Facebook groups because I could tell it was a website. It looked really similar to mine. So I
looked at the Facebook group for that name. Sure enough, I could, I found their, their Facebook
profile. I got, I'm sure I could still find the Facebook messages. So I find the Facebook profile
and I'm like, before I give up on this, let me just reach out to this person and see if they're
because what I did before that guys is I called the website to see if it actually had a client,
right? I didn't call. I didn't click on their ads because they weren't running ads.
I clicked on it. I called and nobody answered. And I did that a couple of times. I was like, dude,
no one's buying these leads. They're not even touching this website and it's ranking.
That's when I reached out and I was like, Hey, my name's Nick, blah, blah, blah. I'm in the same
program. Would you be interested in selling your, your website? Like don't no disrespect,
but I'd love to buy it or talk, talk numbers. And basically this person, they basically got offended
and told me, you know, to go eat sand. And I don't know what it was. And maybe I was having
a bad day, whatever, but I just literally out of spite, I was like, you know what? Screw them.
If you're not going to sell me your website and you don't even have a client, I'm going to build
one anyway. And I'm going to go get a client. And keep in mind at the time we were just now starting
to do rent than rank. I was running ads. So I had this like confidence that, Hey, we can do this in
the city. And I guys, I confidently went into St. George and I landed a client. It was just about
a week after COVID started. I sent a couple of leads, met this guy to coffee shop, totally did
everything wrong. He went and talked to his wife, but because I had sent them the leads and I,
that's when I realized the power of sending leads, by the way that he called me, his name was Tony.
He's like, dude, let's do this. I met him at a Maverick, which is a gas station because it was
COVID outside, literally signed a contract over the hood and had these guys for over three years
before they went a different direction over three years. And I made here, I'll tell you right now,
if I can, if I can pull it up real quick. Oh, by the way, this is nice. I made two, I made
just 150, not much, but I made $150 at 205, which I always love because I love making money when
I'm sleeping. It always feels good. Hold on tree service. Let me see if I can find this company
and tell you guys exactly how much I have made from this website that I almost didn't go into
St. George tree service right there. Where are you at, bro? Okay. St. George tree service leads.
It might not let me, it's going to make me sign in. Hold on. Let me do one more thing. It's called,
um, hold on. I would love to tell you guys the exact amount of money I've made. I just
want to tell you guys how freaking much I would have lost out on if companies, where's that?
Okay. It's not going to let me. Anyway, I know it's, it's well over $20,000 point being is I
almost didn't go into it because I saw another lead generator. I went in, not only did I go in,
I got a client. It was over a thousand dollars a month, had them for over three years. So yeah,
I would have made way more than that. I would have made, uh, over $30,000 and I can find the
number for you, but for some reason, like I, it's the mobile is kind of hard to find. So anyway,
guys, um, when you see other lead generators, what the point is treat them as if they're just
another business, right? As if you didn't know what a lead gen site looked like, as if it's just
another Sally's concrete, Mark's concrete, Jack's concrete, look at the age of the domain, look at
the content, look at the backlinks and treat it like any other website. And if it's still is low
competition, then go into it. Who cares? Just because I have a lead generation site and I have
a client doesn't mean you can guys. I just barely did a YouTube video on Bentonville concrete,
like a couple of weeks ago, maybe a week ago. I think it was a couple of weeks ago. And as I'm
doing the video live, I noticed that the number two result is a lead gen site. So somebody took
my advice. They're like, Hey, this guy has a, uh, a project. This guy has a client, but why can't I
go in have be number two and go and get a client too. And I don't know if they have a client,
but they have a website that's ranking and I'm sure they're getting leads. So just because you
see a lead gen site does not mean it's kind of, it's completely competitive. And so that's the
truth. And that's the things you want to cover. So guys, what we covered today, which we're going
to use this outline to create the digital resource that we're going to set up. So those of you that
are on here in the next seven minutes, um, is number one, what are the factors that matter?
Number two, the telltale signs of a highly competitive area. Number three, the telltale
signs of a low hanging fruit slash a layup area, a gimme a lay down. Um, what also, what it means
when you see home advisor and Angie's list, when they're ranking and what, what, what it means when
you spot other lead gens and what you should do. So that said, guys, are there any comments,
any questions? Jason, if you wouldn't mind, can you go ahead and open that up? And if there are,
let's go through those really quick. Yeah. Yeah. We got a few here. Um, let's see.
So Joel asks, did your view of competition change from your earlier years compared to now?
If so, how? Yeah, because my, I didn't know what proper competition looked like. I didn't have
a formula for proper competition. Guys, if you don't know what to look, what, what, um, metrics
to look at, if you don't know what a good area looks like, you, you can't even do this business
model. Like my, the training I first got, it taught me a lot of basics. It taught me so many good
things and I, I, I spent $8,000 on it. I made a lot of money from it because I taught me things
I had to learn. I had to learn how to do content. I had all these different things,
but I'm going to be honest, the due diligence process, the competition, you know, assessment
part, it was terrible. It was absolutely terrible. It didn't teach me this. So yeah,
it's completely changed and I learned it through trial and error. So, um, basically how it's
changed is, is I now look at age of domain content, backlinks, and then CPC is something
that I can't believe I never looked at. Like, and the reason why guys is the higher the CPC,
typically the more competitive it is. And if you're not, and the other thing is if you're
not looking at CPC, you're crazy because let's just say that winter comes and things dry up or
things slow down or your website, heaven forbid gets, gets pushed to page two or page three for,
for some weird Google update. I want to make sure that if I kick on ads tomorrow to supplement,
I'm not going to lose my shorts. So that, I mean, the other before I wasn't even thinking
about CPC. Now it's a, it's a huge metric that I look at. So anyway, keep going.
Yeah, yeah, for sure. Um, so Chris asks, what are your ballparking,
what are you ballparking for CPC, um, for the UK?
Um, I've never done CPC in the UK, but my, what I would tell you is, you know, obviously less
than $5 because that's what you do in the US, but I would, I would say that you could probably
safely do less than you could probably shave a dollar, maybe a dollar 50 off, because I know
that it's not as competitive. Um, but if you want to be ultra safe, then I would do less than $5
in the UK. Just to say,
if he's using the pounds. Oh, what is pounds? Yeah, just convert it. I don't know. I'll tell
you right now. Yeah, just, just convert it, Chris. Five USD, two pounds.
3.85. So anything 3.85 or less, 3.85 pounds or less per click. You're good to go.
Cool. Swing. Yeah, no problem. Thanks man. Good question.
Uh, let's see, uh, Salim, uh, you said you have a tree service site in San Jose. Nick was talking
about St. George, Utah. I think you're talking about San Jose, California. So completely different
areas. We actually don't even recommend going into California, to be honest. Don't do it.
Don't do it again. This is just coming from experience. I'm like that old grandpa. That's
like, you know, that gives you that wisdom. And they're like, yeah, when I was a kid and you think
they're full of crap and tell you like, go and try it. And they're like, Oh, grandpa was right.
Don't do California, man. I feel exhausted. Like I, I don't even have energy to like really talk
about it because we talked about it. I have a YouTube video about it.
There's too much money out there to be wasted time in California.
Yeah, for sure. Uh, Shane Noble says, Nick, do you use SEO Quake for content?
Where do you get CPC metrics or the keyword planner? CPC, I've always used SEMrush.
However, I think if you've been on my last two, cause you're, he's an indigenous landlord.
The last two weeks, I've kind of talked about it is we've been working for the last year on
putting something together. That's going to be our like go-to golden standard thing. I've put
over, we put over $50,000 into this thing and we're testing it right now. Um, so for right now,
until I show you what I'm talking about, you could use SEMrush. Um, that's what we usually,
that's typically what I'm referring to. That's what I've used in the past.
Yeah, I'm excited for that. Uh, Saleem says, do you suggest using EMD or going, uh,
some other relevant names for domain name? Okay. So for those that don't know what he means
about EMD is exact match domain. Um, you know, St. George concrete, St. George plumbing, whatever
Las Vegas concrete or concrete Las Vegas. Um, yeah, I don't, I try to get it in, but you know,
I don't stress a bunch. So like I do, I still try to get it in. So if I, I always look at,
you know, Las Vegas concrete, second option would be concrete Las Vegas. Third option would be,
uh, concrete hyphen Las Vegas. Uh, then it would probably be concrete hyphen
loss hyphen vague. I try to keep it in, but I don't think it ultimately is that big of a factor
that again, guys, if you look, if you find a city that's low hanging fruit and you do the due
diligence and it's not competitive, that isn't that technically Google says that exact match domain
isn't a factor anymore, but I don't agree. I think it does matter a little bit. And so if you're
going into a highly competitive area, all the tiny things matter, but if you're going into an area
that's not competitive, you can get away with a lot. So my, my recommendation is spend the time
to find a low hanging fruit area, find one of those telltale signs, those map listings without
a website. And then guess what? The exact match domain doesn't really matter. Okay. But technically
Google says it doesn't matter. I still try to get it, but I don't, I'm not too fussy about it.
I don't have to have an exact match domain, but I do try to get at least the keyword in, at least
the city without making it look spammy. Yep. Yeah, for sure. Um, and then she noble says,
have you done any YouTube on CPC? Um, I'm going to write this down. I was going to just think
about making a YouTube on exact match. Um, CPC, I don't know if I've done it too much on that,
but I can Shane. That's a good, that's a good suggestion. I can make a video on CPC. In fact,
what I'd like you to do, Shane, send me a DM with Jason or Donnie Drake. He's also, he's got two
names. Um, send us a DM with your exact question related to CPC. I'll make a YouTube video this
week. I'll post it and I'll send it to you, uh, directly to answer your question and also be able
to, um, have it as a good, you know, piece of information for anyone else has a question.
Also Shane, uh, you're, you're part of digital landlords. Um, I feel like Nick goes over that
pretty well in the training. If you need to go through and review the training or ask people
in the paid group, um, you know, people can help you out there too. So, and also by the way,
I'm going to cover this tomorrow on digital. We're actually doing, we're rehauling the whole
training on ads, which is exciting. I'm pretty pumped about that. But, um, so yeah, Shane,
that's what I would do. I'm happy to make a YouTube video about it. Number one, number two,
like you said, I know this, we've covered it in, in detail, um, in the training and also in the
different threads within the group. Um, but yeah, and you could also ask that question to digital
landlords. And then me and, um, Jason can go answer it there as well.
Yeah. Um, we got, we got one more, I think, uh, Joel, on average, how long has it taken you to
rank aside with ads in a low competition area? Um, have you already screenshot this that people
are on by the way? No, I haven't. You should be done really quick and I'll answer this. We can
hop off to screenshot everyone with their name. And anyone's on this call is going to get a DM
from, uh, Donnie Dre, which is Jason. He's going to DM you the digital resource that we create from
this call. So appreciate you guys being on. Um, this is, I guess my gift to you for just being on
and then you'd have to take a bunch of notes and, uh, we're going to create that today. Um, average
for me, if I do good research is, is four to six months. Um, but there's always anomalies. There's
always times you go in and you surprise yourself and you get something to rank. I've had stuff
rank in a month. I've also had stuff that looked like everything else and it took me nine months.
So you can only control what you can control. But guess what? The beautiful thing is,
is if you're running ads, you're making money the entire freaking time. And so you don't sit
there and obsessing, not sitting there. Oh, where am I ranked? Where am I ranked? Where am I? Right?
Where's the lead? You don't even worry guys. You just go and you make money and you get the next
one, you get the next one, you get the next one. And the thing I love about it, like Jason, for
example, you know, he's making 14 grand a month, but his margins, because he's running ads to keep,
I'm guessing most of those afloat, his margin is the lowest it's ever going to be. Let's say it's
50% right now because he's spent, he's got some that are ranking. He's got a lot of these doing
ads for, let's just say he's making 7,000 net. It's the lowest it's going to be. And what he's
going to realize if he hasn't already is he's going to look at that. He's going to sit down one day
and go, oh my gosh, if I just focus on SEO, if I just focus on getting this rank so I can turn off
ads, I can go from making 7,000 in my pocket to making 12,000 in my pocket. And that's like the
coolest thing because you don't have to call any business owners. You just have to focus on
technical stuff, which is the easy part. And you can make $5,000 more per month in your pocket,
which is what a lot of people get paid per year at their job. So yeah, for sure.
One thing I noticed too is like, I'm just focusing on just getting that next deal,
hooking the next business owner. And the next thing I know a lead comes in organically and I'm
like, Hey, this isn't from the ads. I go take a look and this guy's number two on Google already.
I have three or four guys who are already at the top of Google without adding a single backlink,
to be honest. So just let it do its thing and focus on closing the next deal.
And that means Jason, that you did really good due diligence. If you're ranking without backlinks,
that's because you did a really good due diligence. So that's the truth. Guys,
thanks for being on the call as always. And guys, hopefully you guys listen to what Jason's saying.
Jason, for those that didn't hear this, it started in January, just like this year.
He's already at 14,000. This works for everybody. If you follow the process,
it works for everybody. And so when he's in there as Donnie Dre, if he's given advice,
he's actually doing this. That's kind of a rule. If somebody's on my team, they have to be doing
the business model. They have to have already closed deals. Because if not, imagine Jason's
on this call and he's just speaking from theory. So anyway, if you guys see his post, know that
he knows what he's doing. But that said, guys, thank you so much. We'll see you guys inside the
free group and we'll see you next week. Thanks, Jason. See you guys.